ses partisans le voit déjà de nouveau à
la présidence à peine connue la décision
du juge hudson fac in en soirée qu'ils
étaient déjà dans la rue à saint paul de
orbe also know
si j'étais ball sonar au je ne dormirai
pas tranquille dit cette jeune femme
parce que le 1er janvier 2023 il passera
l'écharpé présidentielle à lula le
président ball sonoro a tout de suite
répondu que ce n'était pas surprenant
car le juge est un sympathisant du parti
des travailleurs de lula paquet lula 75
ans a déjà purgé un an et demi de prison
pour corruption avant d'être libéré par
la cour suprême
il avait été condamné à douze ans de
prison par le juge sergio moreau dans le
cadre du scandale de corruption de la
compagnie d'état petrobras et de la
fameuse enquête lavage à tôt le
procureur général du brésil peut en
appeler à la cour suprême réunie en
plénière mais cela risque d'être inutile
car les onze juges sont déjà en train de
déterminer que le juge moreau a été
partial contre lula si les résultats de
jésus en ces moments et est suspect tous
les les procédés vont être annulées et
sergio moreau était ensuite devenu
ministre de la justice du président
bolton a row avant de claquer la porte
en avril 2020 le juge serge moreau
monsieur anticorruption pourrait être
aussi candidat à la présidence en 2022
et rentrer la réélection de bol sonar ou
encore plus difficile il a déjà un taux
de réjection les électeurs très élevé il
s'appelle cordes et blanc collé et donc
avec des candidats compétitif comme hulu
là je pense qu'il serait compliqué pour
les élections en 2022 non seulement
jaillir ball sonara aura des adversaires
plus solide que la
dernière fois mais en plus il devra
probablement rendre des comptes pour sa
gestion catastrophique de la pandémie et
de l'économie jean michel leprince sera
du canada montréal